his pain is ours  we fail  lose our chance of revenge  when the time comes I'll pull the  trigger  here on out you're on your own  I like working solo anyway you're a  legend in the eyes of those who live on  the battlefield that's why you have to  handle this mission yourself how and  where well that's up to you enemy  presence detected analysis complete  eliminate him however you see fit  don't get spotted  gee mom  schol fates plans to become a nuclear  power  unless we stop it he'll go down in  history a conquering victor we can't let  that happen  you've only got two options  well  no there's another  burn with the rest  boss get out  what goes around comes around you can  run from yourself forever Kaname